he literally realized that he is god
he was literally completely impersonal
with me i was impersonal at that point
i was aware of being aware and he was
impersonal with me and it was just
just beautiful very beautiful
there's no what is blocking the
awareness from being it's already here
it's already ever present awareness is
already aware
there's no there's no blockage that's
just a thought that you
believe but there's an awareness of it
that is the key the awareness is the key
not whatever you think is the key
they they don't realize how significant
uh this awareness is yeah
hey everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host atlas very pumped
for this episode we're going to be
talking about the pathless path
to god realization we have sebastian key
joining us on the show hi savannah hello
everyone
hello
i'm so happy that you stumbled upon
us and then messaged in the comments and
then
we got connected really quickly it's a
divine dream
it is
oh man sebastian is so
unique and
i'll give you a bit of his bio you can
find it
also written below he's a teacher of the
timeless pathless path
to god realization he is unique as he
came to the realization when he was 19
years old
we're gonna be talking about that story
he is the founder
of i am eternal life and he's currently
accepting one-on-one private sessions he
can follow
support him via the links below his
instagram is really poppin we have a lot
of the same teachers it's really cool
stuff there
go check it out website blog patreon as
well really good writings on his blog
and support our man here so you can
continue
with great prosperity thank you everyone
sebastian let's do this okay so were you
were you also
born and raised in israel yes i was in
israel until
just a few months ago there was a point
where
well we can probably discuss this a bit
later but yes i was born and raised in
israel
yes and then
who were your parents how many siblings
did you have so i had
i have one older brother one younger
brother
the older brother is 22 the younger
brother is
14 in a month and two parents
like mother father which are 44
around that area right now so they're
pretty young
and that would be it for now and what
were their professions
um so my dad was working with is working
with computers
stuff like that and my mom is a
photographer
interesting and are there lineages both
israeli no they're from my mother is
from
armenia and my dad is from georgia but
they both
met in georgia but like their lineage
is what i described
so you said your mom's armenian yes
and your dad's georgian yes yes
but they are both mixed also because
like my mom
my mom's mom is um
i'm not sure i'm not sure which one of
them is armenian which one of them
is georgian so but they're both like
very close but my father is mainly
georgian my mother is like half half
probably something like that
but my my my father's
father is jewish also that is why
we were able to come to israel
yeah okay i see i see
this is the first time that sebastian
and i are discovering that we actually
share
lineage as well because both my mom
and my dad are armenian very nice
yeah yeah yes yes you're a man
yeah what did you do why did you just
say
yes yes you're a man i love you sorry
sorry yes kiss serum
i love you oh oh i have no idea i don't
speak armenian but i love you too
[Music]
you speak russian oh my god
we just learned that we both speak
russian what
what oh it's so interesting so did they
both
speak russian also they taught you all
your siblings russian growing up
yes we were like they pretty much knew
only russian
uh i learned um hebrew through school
basically and only later only my father
was learning hebrew kind of like
not uh completely not fluently
but enough to make business and stuff
yeah we were raised in russian oh wow
raised in russian and then picked up
english as a second language and then
hebrew as third is that
through the um well it was russian then
hebrew then english because
uh through the television there were
many
series that were talking in in english
but the subtitles were in hebrew
so i was able to understand what they
are saying based on what is translated
and then i was somehow the brain was
able to
just learn english through that and also
through
playing video games like maple story so
i needed to ask for
money and needed for needed to ask for
help and stuff like that so i also
was talking to people through maplestory
and
games like that so that was also a very
great help to
learn english
oh my gosh this is we just
got this fascinating similarity that
just
came up it's so interesting we didn't
even know this about one another that's
so
interesting my grandma taught me russian
when i was growing up and
i'm so so grateful being being bilingual
and i learned
and a lot of spanish also in high school
and so
being multilingual is
really important it sort of provides
additional
perspectives and you can help people
god realize in many languages in many
languages
yeah yeah exactly i've actually been
practicing that
specific thing um
and there's also a lot of
neuroscientific
benefits as well with gray matter as
we're sort of
progressing into that on a scientific
side of things
sebastian my next question for you
is about who were you
growing up when did you kind of
pick up your interests
even what were your interests before you
got interested in spirituality and stuff
like that and then how did you get
interest in spirituality
okay so so
before spirituality and
i was basically interested in video
games mostly
video games and at like 12 or 13 i
picked up anime from my older brother
so that was pretty much it and i was
skipping school a lot
i hated school like i literally skipped
like 100 days out of 200
um wow so
i was very very uh socially anxious
starting from around age 13 because i
had a lot of friends
oh i also was basically a thief
i was stealing phones and stealing a lot
of stuff from people because
we were poor and i always wanted stuff
because well i wasn't god realized
so i was stealing stuff and still i i
kind of
had friends and stuff like that so uh
i definitely loved spending time with my
friends
listening to music and linkin park stuff
like that
and
um so
um so yeah that was a nice period in my
life until like 13 and from 13
i basically well actually before that at
11 i was
bullied a lot because i was very short
in georgian and there is a
show in israel that basically portrays a
georgian short person on tv and he's
super stupid also
so they called me you you short [ __ ]
georgia and stuff like that so
yeah that was horrible at the time right
now i wouldn't even care
but so i was bullied for that
and but after that i made friends with
these bullies and everyone in class
basically
um but at the moment when
i went from um so from like the starting
school middle school and high school
right how
elementary school so from elementary
school
at the last year i basically uh broke
contact with everyone i knew i
just like in retrospect it was like a
calling from god basically because there
would be no other reason basically
and so i basically just left everyone
they they did not suit my taste
basically i i like there was an
intuition that
they were fake and i did not want to be
with them
wow and so after that i basically
i still had friends a very small group
of friends but
at some point um i became
identified with being socially anxious
depressed
stuff like this and at like um
16 or so it was peaking i really wanted
to kill myself i was browsing some
forums
and sites that were also not very
helpful for that they were only
um making me more identified and stuff
like that that was not the ideal
environment to spend my time in but
right in retrospect it was
it was the ideal environment because
um um that pushed me to to
suicide and because i was pushed to
suicide and i i literally could not bear
the pain anymore
of being identified with being socially
anxious and depressed and stuff like
that
and it was like i had a choice it was
either i'm going to
kill myself or i'm going to have a
mystical experience using psychedelics
so i took the psychedelics with my
friend
and he had a very bad trip but i
actually had a very enlightening trip i
was in the in in the middle of the trip
i basically
what did you take what did you take lsd
i took 150 um
lsd on a sugar cube so
um i basically after a few hours i was
in this place near a lake and i was
looking around
and the trees were alive and i never had
this kind of
thing before because you know so much
identified with thoughts that you don't
even see the aliveness
that is all there is really
you are too identified with all these
concepts
so that was very amazing and definitely
i felt a calling to continue using
psychedelics because i felt like
they could bring me even more
realization more aliveness
and like that was um
i just knew i had to to continue using
it using them and utilizing them
to have the best life because even the
moment even a few hours
after the first trip i basically my
social anxiety vanished
it literally vanished i i went to the
mall
and my friend was more anxious than me
and he's not even socially anxious
he was worried and stuff and i'm like
just going through the
the security guard and i'm i'm pretty
much i'm
tripping right kind of at least like it
was like
eight hours and into the trip so not
really really tripping
but still basically under the effect uh
so
some kind of ego dissolution uh
definitely happened with no doubt
and that basically helped the social
anxiety to vanish
and i felt great for the few days after
okay so i took 200 micrograms of lsd
uh three days later after my first dose
and then we went with my friends to a
restaurant and i
i looked at the restaurant and it felt
like
this was some kind of restaurant for
animals right because on lsd
the the ego is so dissolved they're so
it's it's not human beings anymore it's
you literally see that it's an animal
in front of you basically so um
so i was i was just watching them eating
meat because they were itching eating
like chicken wings and it was just the
most
insane scene ever it was just insane
and then we went outside and i was just
looking at at like i was just walking
and it felt like the sun i never saw the
sun in the sky and it felt like
i don't know how to describe the the
the perception but whatever
whatever there's nothing here that i can
really
um share too much
and so
after that i continued using lsd
like maybe one once in two weeks or so
and at some point actually a few
probably a week after the second dose i
took lsd again 100
150 micrograms and
i actually had like a realization that
like this whole world is for me to
explore like there was literally
that was probably the first one the
first time i i realized
like intuitively right i did not yet
have the concept
that i am consciousness but it was like
i'm totally
free from the past basically i really
really there was a an actual realization
that
like there's there's freedom and there
there's so much to explore
um i cannot really talk too much
um about um
the next trips because i really don't
remember too much
but at some point i also had a trip in
which
um i realized brahman basically i was
looking at the mirror
and there was just
at the time i had no idea what the hell
was happening right but there was just
ego death basically
um with that memory
um it really like it's a very very
strong
memory that pushed me towards
god realization because it was this this
picture
of me looking at the mirror but there
was no
person it was just pure existence
so that was very very powerful
and
wow
that's probably what i'm going to share
for now wait what was the question again
by the way
what exactly was the question how i got
into spirituality let's continue to
to this so at one point i took another
dose of lsd
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i'll hit the ball back and then we'll
keep going
wow oh
wow so
well this is there's a lot of
similarities here
besides our lineages our shared language
i also played a ridiculous amount of
video games growing up
i also listened to things like linkin
park i also
stole a bunch of [ __ ] growing up i was
also bullied
called jelly belly because i was fatter
i also broke contact with a lot of
people
to explore more of the world
now i didn't have ass severe
of what sounds like depression and
social anxiety
like you it was at the level that
basically i could not go to the store
i was afraid to go to school because if
i was late in one minute
there was always this one person who
says oh you are late you are late and i
could not bear that
so basically even when i went to the
store and someone talked to me or
anywhere someone talked to me um
i would i would blush very hard and they
would they would comment on that
and then i would start also that that
that you know like
uh yeah mumbling on your words yeah
and that exacerbated the anxiety even
further
so yeah it's it was and like it was
absolutely insane i was i was totally
uh believing the thought that says i'm
unlovable
unworthy and at the time i was really
identified with the desire
to have a girlfriend and because of the
social anxiety that
basically denied that blocked it that
even the possibility
it was it got me even further into
depression and stuff like this just kept
building up
uh one on top of the other
it's so
much trauma pressure cooking
the piercing of the veilless veil
it was perfect it was yeah it was
perfect yeah
and what
wow it's crazy seeing you
in the state that you're in right now
just
four years later after being so
depressed and social anxiety that you
wanted to commit suicide
and it's so fascinating seeing
that because i it's so insane for me to
imagine you in that previous state
that's like
you know that's a completely different
reality it's so
so crazy so
also what else was interesting was that
there's
a lot of the planet is currently
waking up again to entheogens
psychedelics and their
ability to awaken us
to ultimate reality and
[Music]
in many ways they have been for
thousands of years by indigenous
cultures around the world and then in
the
especially 1960s in the counterculture
it was very quickly seen that
the denuclearization of the family and
too much openness too much liberalism
too much awakening happening too quickly
that needed to be
choked down and so the
complete
illegalization of everything
and that's spreading around the planet
and so it's
really good that you
ended up finding lsd
and this is currently being done by maps
the multidisciplinary association of
psychedelic studies we've had rick
doblin on the show several times we
adore what they're doing across all of
the different entheogens and showing the
the breakthrough properties of them to
this
god realization and during
they got breakthrough therapy awarded by
fda
and i totally support everything all
the all the research done on
substances like mdma and all the other
and theogens also definitely that can
help and heal so much definitely and
awaken of course
yeah exactly psilocybin as well 5mu dmt
ayahuasca peyote
there's many more and even
cannabinoids and
it's really interesting that you were at
such a time that basically required you
to have
something like a breakthrough because
you were so identified with your
thoughts
and you were missing the aliveness and
lsd did the
same thing for me in my really early 20s
where i also saw the aliveness of the
trees and the planet
at that level and that was so profoundly
shifting for me as well so my question
would be
where did you hear about
lsd and how
was the process it sounds like it ended
up being quite easy for you to procure
because you were doing it once every two
weeks you mean
purchase to yeah it's like to get it
from someone yeah yeah
i see so um repeat the question please
how did you hear about lsd
so how did i hear about lsd and how did
i get it okay
so i heard about lsd because i was
looking for medicine
for the social anxiety so the first
things i noticed or
read about were xanax and ssris
but wow i'm willing even to take xanax
every day for the rest of my life i was
so desperate
ssris i read that they only had like 40
to 55
percent success rate so i was like no
this ain't gonna work
basically so i was not willing to take
ssris
but um xanax was
i don't know somehow this dream did not
allow it
basically so um
yeah i continue to continue reading
about
um mystical experiences somehow i
i was i stumbled upon them and
i was reading about shrooms and lsd and
somehow i
was smoking weed at the time right and
you can purchase weed through telegram
very easily in israel you can get all
kinds of drugs
super easily through the telegram so
um i could just purchase
some lsd through the telegram and go to
the other city
take the lsd and go back to my city and
use it
so it was super simple and until the the
day i left i could take like i
could get like dmt changa 2cb
um weed of course lsd shrooms
with mdma of course whatever like
whatever i could easily and readily get
everything i needed
wow you were so pressure
cooked by the suffering
that you were researching xanax and
ssris and so many of the
perverse incentives that exist because
they
are subscriptions for life
and you're like no no no no no no please
tell me what exactly it means perverse
yeah the perverse incentive is like an
incentive that is
not aligned with the two parties it's
aligned
mostly in favor of just one party to
extract
from the other party what exactly is the
point you are trying to make so i can
understand that with
xanax and with ssris
they are basically more like extracting
from one from the victim to the company
because otherwise if we were smart we
would say
instead of xanax and ssri let's give the
person
an entheogen and they can like you were
researching
they can break through more efficiently
so basically they want you to make
to make you a slave zombie for life
basically
that's not ideal for the society but it
is ideal for the companies that are
making money
is this what you're saying
yeah it's it's yeah that's it's worded
aggressively
slave zombie for life yeah yeah yeah
exactly but really though um so that's
what we call perverse incentives is
things like
yeah wow and so i'm so happy that you
could just get on telegram and get some
and
okay cool so that's how that happened
and then i'm really happy that you had
that trees becoming
alive uh for you and it's a really
interesting story that you tell about
being so
caught up in thoughts and then also
that you weren't able to see that and me
too i was also like that and then in the
early 20s i saw that and i was like
blown away by that and then
it was interesting your story about when
the when that default mode network
in neuroscience when there's that
the mental models and concepts that we
have about
the world when they are so
aggressively tight on
our world view that
it makes it so that we can't even see
how silly it looks
to see humans sitting there eating
chicken wings and they're human
they're human animals and but you saw
that because you had that
loosened your world view and that
tightness was loosened
through the anti-agents and you were
able to see that and those were some
profound revelations for me as well
another
massive similarity and so
i like the what you said about the whole
world
is free you're free to explore the whole
world how that
revelation came and it was sort of some
of the initial
uh becoming more interested in what the
freedom or what that consciousness is
and then it sounds like several trips
later maybe like was a six or like 12
trips later that you were looking at the
mirror uh oh
probably like around six six trips or so
okay so six trips so now
let's start here and then we'll keep
going on the spirituality
so okay so i said what they sorry yeah
continue so
specifically this question is before we
keep going on spirituality is
take us to what happened when you were
looking at
the mirror and was this also
on uh lsd or
it was okay so this was like the seventh
trip or something like that
let's say yeah i really don't remember
it not something like that yeah exactly
cool okay so what happened well what
nothing happened
that was the first time nothing happened
right because always something is
happening oh this is happening this is
happening but there was just pure
awareness basically
there was no actual realization that
this is pure awareness
but in retrospect i could look at that
and uh see what actually happened there
right with the
later um um intellectual understanding
that i built on top of all of this eagle
dissolution
happenings so after that
um i also had another trip a few trips
later probably i really don't remember
exactly wait i i wanna i want you to
unpack the
moment if you remember it any more
detail i would love for you to unpack
sort of the when you're
you're sebastian key and you're looking
at yourself in the mirror
and then within a couple of
moments you kind of recognize the
awareness
itself and so exactly
it was not that i recognized the
awareness it was like the ego dissolved
so i did not even recognize the
awareness at the time there was just
bliss pure freedom that was what
was happening and i don't have too much
memories from that day itself
okay i do remember i want to share that
there was one day
where i took the lsd and i was listening
to music outside on the on the
on the rooftop basically and i was
listening to music and
and man i was going crazy i was going
crazy
i was listening to trans music and i was
super shy i could not even dance with
myself like i
i did not have the like there was too
much ego and identification so you could
not
i could not even let loose with my own
self right
so yeah i took the lsd and i started
dancing and it was super free super fun
super blissful
and possibly it was this day that this
happened
and one day i was also like i'm just
sharing right now
some lsd experiences i was looking at
the sky
and like there was just so much bliss
just
insane insane bliss because you are so
present
with no ego right so at the time
you are identified with the ego so the
bliss looks insanely insanely strong
right now there is bliss
but it's like it's like the bliss is
normal at this point
it's like you're stabilized uh in the
bliss as the bliss
so it would not be so amazing right
but at the first time when you are still
identified
and you realize there is bliss then it's
amazing uh so i wanted to share that
and a few trips later i took another uh
lsd i'm not sure how much it was
um and i pretty much realized that i'm
eternal
like it well again it none of it is
intellectual at all
at that point it was i was just sitting
on my chair
my mom was in the in the other couch
and i was just like i was pure awareness
basically
there was absolutely no ego that was
like probably the most
um that was the the strongest
you could say ego death that i ever had
it was like
i was literally god at that point um so
i was
i was literally looking just at a pure
um like just my my apartment right
and it was eternal it was literally
eternity
it was realized that this is eternity
literally this is eternity
there was also an intuitive recognition
that there is the conditioned mind
i still have no intellectual
understanding of anything happening even
at this point
but there was an intuitive realization
that there is an egoic mind and i need
to fight for my
spot as pure awareness um
um so it's like you become a
like an intuitive realization of being a
spiritual
warrior that what that's what it was
basically
um yeah this is what i wanted to share
and this is
um for for now if you have any comments
i can continue to um
yeah but i can continue see if you have
any comments yeah thank you
my
primary comment here is that
i love how in a sense
lsd and entheogens in many ways
they dissolve that contracted energy
of the separate egoic entity and then
they enable the
god realization in many ways it's
in a sense it was like training wheels
it sounds like for you it was kind of
like training wheels into bliss
seeing bliss feeling bliss etc was like
training wheels
and then eventually you stabilized
without lsd in a sense and that
became the god realization that's sort
of how the yeah
i'm not finished with the with the story
so i would like to expand on that
yeah yeah good good okay yeah and i love
how you recognize that even
the moment of being in your apartment
you just recognized eternity as well
it's not just that it was clear
yes clear yeah yeah yeah yeah i even
know that
i'm posting in the instagram like listen
guys we are literally in eternity right
now
celebrations stuff like that exactly and
that's why
people like francis lucille who's the
teacher of
rupert spyro and one night he calls all
of this happening he calls it the
eternal fireworks the fourth of july
celebration eternal fireworks is a very
good description also i i resonate with
that
yeah yeah exactly and it's like actually
the awareness that is you know like it's
basically like a firework itself it is
the source firework
that every single moment it's it and
it's basically
this whole dream is like the the after
effect
of the firework the firework itself is
like the source and everything that
appears
in front of the firework is whatever is
happening right now
oh yeah yeah brilliant
exactly brilliant yeah so
so i love that realization of eternity
it's so
important especially in the modern world
because the belief of physicalism
infinity and time and
ego and all those beliefs
one needs to in a sense reject
those and take this intuitive leap to
eternity and that's
one of the away to
one of the pathos paths and
and i'm glad that that was a it's a
yeah it's so beautiful so far let's uh
let's continue
and i'm glad that we also got to those
fireworks oh my gosh those
analogy i know yeah okay
so and there was another trip
um wait a moment
okay there was another trip where
basically um
law of attraction was realized basically
on an experiential level because again
on lsd basically all of these
realization
realizations i have no idea what any of
these things
are literally they're just spontaneously
arising
and being revealed to in front of the
consciousness
so um
so law of attraction was realized again
i cannot i don't want to
right now experience um sorry
conceptually and
tell you what it actually how i see it
right now
like how i would explain it we can go
into that
but um at that same day
there was a person i was um browsing
reddit
and there was a person who sent me a
message
on exactly four four four
and then he started talking to me and he
he
told me that he felt a calling to send
me a message and to share with me some
resources about god realization
and he sent me a muji on youtube
perfect so um yeah
i talked to him for like an hour and 11
minutes
so we ended the conversation on five
five five completely spontaneous just
random so um
yeah after a few weeks or so i started
looking into that
and i started watching muji that was
um very resonating but still i was not
extremely consistent with that so i
watched it i watched it like
but still ha i was working at my
part-time job and
well it was not really part-time i can't
say
in domino's pizza so yeah
and you're like 18 years old or
something right now yeah yeah
okay so so you weren't
yeah it's not full-time dedication to
yeah to get to god realization quite yet
yeah exactly
exactly it was like eight hours a day
i was working in domino's pizza yeah so
um
where was i and by the way i have a
question quick before we keep going
you got the muji resources we'll we'll
get right back we'll get right back to
it
what was the reaction of
your mom dad and two brothers
to you using lsd and
healing and healing from your depression
and social anxiety
so um basically i for
the first time i did it i did not tell
them right i was i just
took it and after a day later i told
them listen i took lsd
and they were like they were pretty much
okay with it
they were okay with it and
after like half a year
and they were like pretty much okay with
it yeah really
that's great yeah yeah that's great
exactly yeah no
and especially if you're telling them
that you're healing depression and
i did not tell them that i just took
another because
at the time i did not know what exactly
were the effects
other than i'm not sure if i even
mentioned that
it helped it helped my social anxiety i
did tell them that it is
for depression and social anxiety yeah
and i believe i told him i believe it
can help me
but there were no actual um i could not
say
this is going to work definitely got it
got it so
that's great that they had enough
openness yeah because
yeah because if fam is takes the hammer
down and begins to beat the
entheogen out of the the child's
interest
that's in society doing that too that's
it's all changing more enlightened
civilization yeah continue please
it's a divine dream indeed so yes yes
the gods helped me yes so
exactly so you're yeah so you got them
so interesting you got
at 444 you got the god realization and
muji resources from someone
on reddit and you're working eight hours
a day at domino's pizza
the call ended at five five five i love
this
so you asked about how they um
they what what were the effects
um after the lsd and how it affected my
family
so around half a year later for because
at this point i was pretty much exp a
bit experienced
with the psychedelics so they saw an
amazing and and like it was like
a person that is socially anxious and
depressed
is now extremely joyful all the time
basically well not all the time because
there was still no
stable god realization but a [ __ ] ton of
ego was dissolved
pretty much like and it didn't didn't
come back still
some ego was there was still
identification with thoughts there is no
doubt
um was but um
so um how it affected
the family so half a year later or so
they saw the the
the um the huge change
and they decided that they are also
going to use lsd
what
my aunt started using lsd also because
it saw how
how amazingly it changed me and my older
brother also started using it
and my mom started using it and my dad
experimented with it
and we started basically using
psychedelics um
regularly in the whole family except my
little brother right
oh my gosh this is the future
this is nice let me tell you even though
even though
they did use the lsd they did not really
go for
god realization even though i was there
to like a few years later i told him
listen listen this is
god realization like this is the only
thing that even that matters
but they were still not willing to let
go of their attachments of how they saw
life and stuff so like i cannot say it
was probably
helped in some way to expand their
consciousness but
and not forgot realization so yeah um
it can still help people to
um have a a bit more fulfilling life
and be less identified with their
thoughts but
like ideally you would just use that and
utilize that for god realization not
just take it and have some ego
dissolution
but actually go all the way because
otherwise it's like for me
uh like i don't i don't see a point in
that like
go all the way a point and at the same
time it was like
yep go all the way yeah
charles bukowski love that one go all
the way
yup and that's what the perennial wisdom
is about is drilling all the way
through the veil all the way to the
ocean
all the way to god realization and
through the veilless veil and it's cool
that
fam ended up expanding their
consciousness
in that sense and so now we go back to
the story where you got the resources
yes
we got the resources yes so pretty much
i'm not sure even how much time has
elapsed at that point
but around probably around half a year
after the resources or a year after the
resources i started going
into it um more strongly
and at some point i wanted to leave my
family because i pretty much literally
because i was so
um i saw reality so clearly that they
actually were looking like demons to me
right yeah yeah not like um like an
egoic
um thought that they are demons no just
they are literally completely delusional
and they are perpetuating ignorance and
suffering and are not willing
to open up to god right so yeah
you are pretty much a demon in my
perspective
so wow you are very
wow wow wow wow okay just
just because even here
is such a sensitive thing where
we were talking about this for a little
bit when we first started chatting
before we
recorded where there's so much
attachment to
and that i'm
i must be the one that
brings god realization to my family
and there's
that level of attachment is not wise
it's not graceful and also to
have the wisdom to look at
the expression
the dreamed expression of what they are
and see that their level is in a more
egoic
contracted state and if they're
delusional and they're perpetuating
suffering and that they're not opening
up to
god realization to know how to
gracefully distance yourself in this
case you'll
explain your next steps and your
trajectory here to us in a moment
but to also have the bravery and the
courage to do that
so i just want to plant a big flag here
because it's really
important for other people to hear
this because it's the wisdom
to be able to distance yourself
from your family into
what is more space
and freedom for yourself to bathe in the
god realization to abide
in it more and more and then and then
opened you up to things like potentially
us
now and what's gonna flower even more so
so just a big flag here
for people just remember
that these are some of the most
important
bifurcations in the trajectory
is to be wise
and recognize when to leave the
nest in that pursuit of
piercing the veilless fail yeah okay
definitely
at that point it was like it was even
like
a bit scary like it was not like and
again it's
it's it was not an egoic fear it was
literally
a fear that that uh
like it's god telling you listen this is
not
it this is not it you really need to get
out of here
you really need to get out of here i
cannot really
explain the kind of fear drive
that is pushing you to actually detach
from your family
i also want to go back a little and
share
one time i took an lsd trip again and i
went to the rooftop and i was just
sitting
in a in a meditative pose even though i
don't really think it
mattered much anyway i had this
realization of how much suffering there
is in the world and how it's
absolutely insane but there was like
compassion was absolutely
overflowing i i knew that
uh i'm here to to be
the peace the love the compassion and
the wisdom for
everyone in this planet like
it was like a point of of recognized
responsibility that i have to god
realize i have to be
god for everyone i cannot like it's not
a um
and it's not about anyone else it's
literally just um
for for for for existence basically it
was like an existential
responsibility to be what you are to be
loved because nobody is embodied nobody
even knows what love is they
associate love with attachment that's
like the the furthest
thing from love it's selfishness so
yeah i wanted to share this um
beautiful i had a similar experience
like that
as well so i love that all right so
now you have this courage and the
bravery to actually
go and how do you piece together that
and then how do you piece together the
kind of
the finances and actually pulling the
because you have like yeah yeah four
thousand shackles it's like
um twelve thousand dollars saved from my
job
so i could just leave like i could just
leave
the the home at some point there was uh
the decision
appeared to leave that the house
and to just go to some other place
um is this like is this like september
2020 or something
it was um no that was
in 2019 in around november or sorry
october
okay october 2019
so a year a year ago and like three
months ago
yes and and so so yeah so where did you
go
first because this is before bulgaria so
where did you go first
yeah so i went to switzerland to meet up
with a friend but that did not work
out because it was extremely expensive
there
so i can share another experience that
happened there
that at some point i did not want to
spend any money because it was
extremely expensive it was like 120
for one night stay in a hotel
in like the cheapest hotel there so i
could not afford that so
at the uh at the first day in
switzerland
i basically slept outside in some kind
of cabin
of the bus station yeah it was super
cold
yeah and but at like 7 00 a.m i just
realized okay this ain't gonna work i
have to buy a room
and i'm just going to fly from here to
thailand because
the island is extremely cheap so i could
spend my time there
so yeah but at some point i wanted to go
to the airport in switzerland to fly to
thailand
and a car stopped me on the highway and
they told me what are you doing on the i
on the highway come into the car and i
was there
okay let's go into the into the car and
they drove me to the airport and bought
me some um
some food and some water and then they
ordered even a
hotel room for me they literally ordered
a hotel
okay for free and the room number was
two two two it wasn't really the same
for me
and i just decided like there was the
decision appeared
to take 400 micrograms of lsd and that
was tell
let me tell you that that was not a
smart decision
that was like i went extremely into an
because the ego resisted so
um yeah i got into
a delusional loop of absolute paranoia
and i thought that these two people who
ordered the room for me
they were going they specifically did
that to
then uh kidnap me and kill me that i
actually believe that so i just took the
most
uh valuable stuff like my phone and my
wallet and i just ran outside of the
hotel
i started running like like literally
the fastest i ever run probably like
uh well i don't know i don't want to say
a speed for no reason but i literally
just
zoomed out of there okay i was i was
running for like
probably a kilometer at least just
sprinting
and because you are on lsd you have this
extreme
uh power in your in your everything you
are you are just
um you are able to run super fast and
super
uh powerfully i cannot explain but these
are one of the effects of lsd you can
also
um work out uh more effectively and
stuff like that so you could pro you can
probably run
more effectively also and at some point
i i just sat down and i i needed to
relax but
everywhere i looked even there even
though there were pretty much no cars
i was extremely paranoid i really wanted
to just
sit down and meditate so i went i looked
up
a park at the nearest park on the map
and i wanted to go there and so i
started walking but
the park the park was closed so i sat
near a
a building i just sat there was doing
nothing
and some car drove by and the
guy went out and he told me what the
hell are you doing here what are you
doing
i i was like it was like 3 a.m right and
i'm just sitting there like what the
hell am i doing there
it would look weird to anyone right and
he was like what the hell are you doing
here but
it appeared to me as if he was
aggressive and the paranoia was still
there
so i was pretty sure he's going to get a
gun out of his pocket
so i was just okay okay i'm leaving i
zoomed out of there as [ __ ]
so i zoomed out of there to the another
park and then i was i i got a bit
more detached from that and i just
called the taxi okay let's go back to
the room
um and then i just slept and stuff like
that i started
reading about healing the inner child
which
actually was probably a waste of time
because the inner child is the one that
you should slaughter that is basically
the egoic mind that is the one
that is blocking your god realization
basically so healing that is pretty much
a waste of time in retrospect
but whatever it happened also i utilized
a lot of mdma
well not a lot probably like three four
times
to heal and open up
because the first time i did it it was
insane it was
it was super profound i also candy
flipped lsd with mdma
and that was super super amazing let me
tell you these substances are super cool
so um okay so
uh where was i on the storyline
so you went to sleep about
yeah the switzerland moving so after
that i went to thailand and i took
okay so you did wow okay
cool i was i because this is interesting
to
make the transition to to thailand and
also
that that trip that you had
that sort of it's it's sort of important
to have this
wide variety of trips where
there are these experiences that
are like what you described a delusional
loop and
and it's it's it's important to show
i've had i've had something like that
totally yeah so that is why now sorry
no go ahead yeah good okay so now that
is why i recommend because
i don't really like a lot of people
swear by
having this delusional loop on lsd
everyone is saying no if there's
no anxiety then it's not good but that
is just their egoic mind it wants to
still be attached
that is why they like the anxiety they
say the anxiety is necessary in the
trips
because that is exactly what is holding
you
um still identified but if there was no
anxiety you could just
realize god a completely complete ego
dissolution
with no resistance some people just want
anxiety because they are afraid of
completely letting go
so that is why i recommend using
utilizing fanny bot
substance that kills anxiety it's legal
pretty much everywhere
and you take that alongside the lsd and
you just have the most blissful
god realization trip so you you don't
need the anxiety you don't need the
delusion loop it's not necessary
um in my perception right now so
uh yeah that's what i wanted to see yes
and
agreed that the
more intelligent and wise that we become
the less we'll perpetuate the ignorant
delusional loops and the more
we'll be able to as children just
infants just come
into the world is to
help with the pedagogy and the
the infrastructures for god realization
at very young ages so okay so yeah
and available because there was one
experience when i tried to enlighten my
little brother
right and i told him listen what is this
reality what
is what is everything right and he
actually realized experientially that
this is a dream and he was like
ah he was literally as if he was on mdma
he was just 12. he was
ex just absolutely blissed out he
literally
realized that he is god he was literally
completely impersonal with me i was
impersonal at that point
i was aware of being aware and he was
impersonal with me and it was just
just beautiful very beautiful
because it's just well you cannot really
explain the connection that is between
oneself with oneself like myself with
you right now because
we are literally one well there is no
personal identity which is
the the most [ __ ] thing ever
so from from switzerland i flew to
thailand and i had
another trip with the fanny bot this
time i took one
sorry 1000 micro
so what what is this what so what is
fanny
f h e n penny
i b u t but
b
oh and also spelled f-e-n-i-b-u-t
yes uh it's a central nervous system
depressant used to treat anxiety
insomnia for a variety of other
indications it's like many people
describe it
close to mdma or close to
an alcohol high but without the
the confusion it's super clear super
sober
and you just have bliss and ego
dissolution basically
okay so close to an mdma high and
super light basically and it's like 12
to 18 hours
12 to 18 hours yeah but it's very light
at some point
oh okay okay okay it's like it peaks
after three hours for like six hours or
so
and then it's a it goes down
and then you call it candy flipped when
you add
the lsd to it no uh candyflip is when
you add mdma to ls
lusty and then when you add fendi but to
lsd we don't have a name but
we can probably make something make
something up okay okay
cool cool and i see that the fenny butt
is also the
prescribed in russia i wonder if that's
where it's
probably okay but it's available like
you can order it in the
in europe or in the us you can probably
okay cool okay so then you did this
in thailand yes so i took 1 000
micrograms which
which is a medium dose and i took 200
micrograms of lsd
and that was the most blissful
experience
ever like there was just how are you
getting
these in thailand are you are you
bringing these on the air
yeah i took it on there
i hid it inside the fanny bot bottle the
tabs
and so yeah wow okay
continue yeah you had a very blissful
experience okay extremely blissful
experience it was that
like complete complete ego death okay
um and there was just so much gratitude
and love
for um myself as the
as the fifth diamond i was looking at
the mirror and there was a recognition
that
this is this is like literally a fifth
dimensional being
right now which i'm perceiving right and
and i was that i was like that which is
perceiving behind the eyes
i was the spirit itself so i was the
screen just empty screen
and it was super clear and just
gratitude so much love for myself
um as spirit not as a person
so it was just amazing amazing amazing
amazing
and yeah this is what i wanted to share
and from there um this one
okay okay so in thailand after a month
or a month and a half later
i was sitting in my room i had pretty
much no lsd left i only had funny but
but i was not using funny but on that
day i started reading the book of
gangaji
you are that yeah so because i had these
experiences on lsd i realized what it is
referring to
is the this this loving awareness
that i fell in love with basically um
so i just realized that okay i i am that
i'm just not going to believe
any thought any feeling anything that
tells me otherwise
i'm just not going to believe that i
know i just know it
and it was just it was not not just
intellectual i just
like there was just this spontaneous
recognition that i am that like
everything makes sense basically and so
from there started abiding as the
awareness
like always in remembrance of what i am
yeah
and a month later i started um
well even at that point i started
writing on reddit a lot of posts
helping people to realize what they are
and i was recommending the utilization
of substances also
um but yeah so i'm saying that
um i was really um
um pretty much god realized a year
and two months ago yeah yeah december
2019 right
it was probably like november or
december yeah
cool cool so beautiful
from there yeah i just continued on this
um
helping people and continuing utilizing
psychedelics for uh uh even for
further like dissolving of whatever
remnants
whatever contraction ever right because
you have this guidance on rupert spires
channel also
these yoga meditations that are are
there to help you to
to unpack all the whatever is left and
continue dissolving it because it's an
unending process
so i kept using that and dissolving
more and more and more for the god
realization to flourish more and more
and more
um and i left the family right because i
saw they are very
much delusional and i have no interest
in staying with them i was
literally like no just remove myself
from that completely
but at some point i went back
and
after a while it was realized again like
no
no no no no no just no and this now
i left this uh four months ago
okay so okay so you left uh like around
the beginning of 2020 from thailand back
to israel
uh yeah yeah it was around february
oh interesting my father
did not yet come back to israel because
he was stuck
in georgia because of the covet that
arised so i was still
just with my mother and i helped her
realize all kinds of stuff
and it did help her but it like she was
not willing to just let go
exactly um drunk
every day and i told her listen this is
not going to help you with god
realization
and she told no okay listen i know this
is important but she probably only said
that because i was pushing her to that
and i'm not going to be an officer that
that is everything i'm looking at you
and telling you what to do right i'm not
going to um
like pursue you for this if you don't
want it
you just don't want it exactly exactly
oh yeah at some point
my father came back and then i saw just
just how delusional they are how they
have these
[ __ ] arguments over nothing and they
suffer for no reason
and it's just what the hell am i
watching and it's it was just
super just just silliness
and i realized i'm just leaving this is
not going to work i
i have no interest in that and i left
four months ago
and with the finances now i was just
using the
finances that i had from donations that
i met made the instagram page and i was
asking for donations because
um i knew that i i have to leave
and the moment i had like one thousand
dollars
i just left i just like i don't know how
i'm going to bring
more money or whatever i just trusted
that
this is what i have to do there's no
other option so i just left i just
left on the moment's notice yep exactly
and yeah just uh yolo yeah yeah yeah
yeah and here we are now okay
so
i love how you
in thailand
ended up recognizing that
you are that and also the abiding
which is which is it this that's
we we are in the non-dual tradition we
are already it
always and in the dualistic concession
it's ah there's something to do there's
something to seek there's an abiding
that needs to happen i need to abide
more and more to it and
which will unpack more in a bit
but and i'm glad that you found that
that's so
critical and then that
as rumi says the diamond necklace that's
already around your neck
and then again there's this thing it's
just it's always
it happens so much to people where
there's like i'm gonna
go back home i'm gonna do the god
realization for these closest
people in my life and it and again it
just it didn't work
and it was very clear to you and then it
was like time to
go to the next step fundraising via the
instagram i'm glad people
came in and helped you out to be able to
leave to bulgaria
and i'm also really glad that you caught
on
quickly about the family has [ __ ]
arguments for no reason
that is the essence of
the perpetuation of delusional
suffering and
to recognize that is really important
and then to gracefully and wisely
distance um so it's good so
okay so now you left approximately in
is that september 2020 to bulgaria or so
yeah it was october again actually it
was just a month
a year later after the first time i left
perfect perfect okay bulgaria october
2020 and then
so um so since then
you spent about three months there so
and most recently about two weeks ago
moved to istanbul turkey so
because that's how long you can stay
three months at a time
without visa just okay so
what did you in the last three months it
looks like
as i look through your your instagram
and you look through ours you very
clearly
see that we're
we're getting transmissions from many of
the same people so what have you been
doing these three months in past three
months in bulgaria first
let's start there so
um
pretty much just abiding yeah
like uh what can i say more yeah i don't
know
at some point i ordered some lsd and
fenny bud
there was a calling to again utilize
these substances and
go even deeper into this
and yeah this is what was happening
we can say cool and what is your
for you what does the abiding process
look like over those three months
i don't i don't really know how to
really explain this
but
i i really i really don't know how to
even comment on that because
if someone asks me how to
like what do i do with this okay i
realized i'm the awareness
or like there's an awareness ever
present awareness
i would tell just um
like ideally you would realize there's
an ever-present awareness and
it would just just be enough because
like that that's it and it abides by
itself like the awareness is
abiding by itself it's not like someone
is doing something
yeah but um i guess if you are too
identified even if you notice there's an
ever-present awareness somehow you get
pulled into the delusion loop
and it doesn't necessarily happen on
psychedelics you get into
delusional sober also yeah like you were
saying with your
when your family's having stupid
arguments that's pretty
mine and minus two that's the delusion
loop exactly it happens to sober people
with their ego all the time exactly
that's like actually 99
of people are all in a constant uh
delusion loop yeah yeah so
yeah i guess if someone is is frequently
getting into these
then i would tell them no listen just
don't identify don't identify so
probably that was the key don't identify
it was not that
i'm abiding as the awareness i'm being
aware of being aware it was more like
i just um notice whatever appears
whatever thought appears
or whatever feeling or sensation appears
and just don't identify
the abidence happens by itself the
awareness is already here
just don't believe any thought emotion
sensation perception or experience don't
identify with it the awareness will stay
clear by itself
yes yes
for me it's been a lot similar
to that so
there's almost a
[Music]
relaxing in a sense backwards
inward as well has been kind of also one
of the
the feelings and the analogies
that we use so frequently are really
salient the
the emotion thought feeling perception
belief
object is the cloud
and to recognize yourself as the sky
the ever present awareness of the sky
yeah and that sort of
the analogies whether it be also the
ocean the ocean
and then the waves or the
the blank paper and the words
or the even in the modern world the
screen
and then all of the modulations which
is one of the analogies that you used
earlier when you
had that abiding process awakened to you
felt the emptiness of the screen and
that's what it is it's the emptiness of
the screen and we talked about the
fireworks analogy so the empty screen
gets the
eternal fireworks display
would probably be like
a metaphor means like or
another word for life oh analogy analogy
yeah so so the screen
like there is no real separation between
the screen
and the movie right but if you use the
fireworks
it's like the fireworks is the projector
and
it's always like burning every single
moment it's showing the screen right and
the screen is what's happening basically
like
the movies was what's happening from the
projector so that's like the sky
and the the clouds passing and the sky
is the
the firework basically but of course you
go further into it and you realize
that actually whatever appears in the
sky
or in the in green is just the screen
itself modulating the pixels of itself
appearing as if there's a but actually
the screen alone is there
so it sounds like
something important that
has been helping is
the faith and the trust and the
surrender
because there's been a good amount of
people that have come and
helped support you and
i'm so happy that that's happened that's
critical
and hopefully we can help be a resource
for that as well
yeah that
that the love that was revealed
through ego dissolution and through ego
death
it's like you just know something is
here for you
so it's like you can just throw your
life away basically
in trust and faith and you just know
that that something
loves you so much that you just can't
trust it you literally just just
you know it's it's not like even you
have faith or
you believe or hope it's like you just
know there's so much love that
wow i'm really happy that we got through
the
story because my goodness
that's very unique it's very unique and
it's
and there's critical components to it
like
the massive pressure cooker
suffering being like a drill sergeant
and then finding the entheogens
that is actually why i want to expand on
my posts
why i'm so aggressive because i am being
that this drill
sergeant basically and it helps people
push even if they
unsubscribe unfollow they hate me it
still
touches something inside them that that
makes them
realize that this is not how life should
be this is not my full potential
and this even just one past being read
so aggressively they just that that
in the long term it somehow helps
interesting
so i noticed that about
sebastian's posts on
instagram i am eternal life the links in
the bio
below that
they're very very god realized
and they're also very aggressive so as
he just described a moment ago he's
acting like the drill sergeant and i
think that's a really interesting angle
because basically
everybody else in the god rely space
is doing it like an angel
and so in a sense
i do my best to kind of be somewhere
along the middle grounds
of that and i do think there's a massive
role
for the more hyper direct aggressive
yeah there's something that when i took
the lsd
and there was this initial ego
dissolution
god that was realized basically because
you are much more open to god and its
intelligence
flowing through your body mind and it
was very
direct very tough love you understand so
it really resonates with me because
that's how
that that's literally how god loved me
he loved me
with not like petting me necessarily
it was very tough very very fierce
so i just follow my spirit
wow i see
i see see god's love for you
was really hard drill sergeant-style
awakening
and so you follow that spirit and
passing it along
yeah yeah i'm following but
at the same time it was fierce at times
at times it was also very very like
totally like
feminine right there was the masculine
love that is very tough
and there is also the feminine side of
god's love
that is much more gentle much more
just just hugs you just gives you a kiss
on my end i've had
similar style yin yang
of that more
drill sergeant mixed with the more
warm bath in a sense
and
[Music]
in combinations of the two and it's yeah
it's been it's
yeah those are i'm loving it loving the
loving the convo
i'm so happy that we that we did the
unpacking because so many profound
insights happened
for me along the way as well around just
the
sheer importance of entheogens is a
really important one
um because
and the perverse incentives of a lot of
the
pharma and
i like how we got to eternal fireworks
god realization stabilization and the
bliss those are so good so good
um getting being wise and separating
oneself from
delusional family perpetuating suffering
abiding as awareness recognizing you are
that
all right let's do some of the topics
that we like
discussing on the show the journey was
so so beautiful
i love it i love it so
let's start with let's start with
simultaneity
another way to say it is integrality so
being integral
please expand on this yes yes feel free
to ask anytime
so
integral is when
everything is accounted for
similarly with simultaneity it's when
simultaneously everything is accounted
for
what exactly do you mean by everything
is accounted for it means everything
it's like everything and nothing
it's when in this case let me i'll just
explain it and then
we'll go we'll hear how you how you
think from here so when
when we say simultaneity what we say is
what happened like a thousand years ago
was the
formulation of the taijitsu which
is the monist symbol
that also has the yin and yang within it
so it's the monism one with the yin and
yang so it's trying to showcase
the expression of the non-dual with the
expression of the duel
so the dual within the non-dual yeah
exactly
so the dualistic concession within the
non-dual exactly yeah
and so that's why the idea of
simultaneity has become really important
or integrality
which is that it's not that
it's not just that everything
simply is and isn't
just non-dual but it's also the
dualistic concession
which is that there is something to seek
there's something to do
because when somebody has suffering
what they're looking for is they're
looking for the vortex of people at the
top of the mountain
that are like what you had like why did
the person send you muji
right they could have easily sent you
like some other
like self-actualization coach like a
self-help
book right but they sent you muji which
is a lo which is self-realization or god
realization
so there is some sort of in a sense a
hierarchy to the dualistic concession
in the terms of people around the planet
that understand the absolute that
understand
infinity that understand nonduality that
are enlightened that are god realized
etc
and so for us to
hold both at the same time where a
non-dual
there's nothing to do everything already
is and isn't
that's it and then b which is
there's a dualistic concession which is
there is a mountain so we call this the
flat mountain
so the flat is the non-dual and the
dualistic concession is the mountain
so how do you feel about
because obviously we can't describe the
ineffable
and so the number one thing is to just
not use symbols to try and describe the
indescribable just just abide as
peace and bliss and child like awe
and wonder and just surrender to the
flow
surf on the crest of the expression
that you are
in the dream but then there's also the
along with the ineffable there's also
the
well one of the most fun things to do is
for us to try
and use symbols to play as close as we
can to the ineffable
so how do you feel about
about that um
can you like formulate the question in
uh yeah let me try
so how do you feel about the ineffable
how do you feel about
trying to use symbols to describe it
like what we were saying with
simultaneity
like the absolute yeah yeah
i don't really describe it um
at all it's lit it's literally ineffable
it's literally beyond
all description beyond beyond the
awareness itself
yeah so i don't even
even touch that subject unless someone
approaches me
and asks like what what is that
and then i would i would tell him that
that's where the awareness comes from
yeah exactly yeah that's the perfect
[Laughter]
answer
oh that's good
so actually a few months ago when i i
took my first
big dose in a while lsd of lsd like it
was like um
120 right so
i took the dose and there was this
realization of that which is
dreaming the awareness itself yeah
that is the absolute it cannot be
perceived it's but it is recognized
that it is literally dreaming the
awareness in which everything appears
so it's like that that's that's the
clearest way
that i describe it yeah
it is it is yeah
from my understanding that's the
clearest way to describe it as well yeah
ah
if somebody comes up to me and asks me
well what is that absolute
oh that's where the awareness comes
it's actually funnier than than it was
perceived before
it is so funny laughing at this because
it's really it's so profound
and yet it's like so simple it's like
yeah yeah yeah yep
[Music]
that which dreams the awareness
because i also watched some of bentino's
videos of the infinity series yeah
and it was very um resonating because i
had the intuitive recognition of what
of the absolute but he actually
explained
that there's this like the
the infinite infinity itself
uh dreams like a bubble of consciousness
that's
just the pure awareness that is eternal
relatively and in the
awareness appears like whatever comes
and goes right
but uh even even like the awareness
itself it's it's
timeless but it's it's still
it came from somewhere it's not
literally the the
the infinity itself even though it is
unlimited whatever appears in it
anything can appear in it in that way it
is unlimited
and uh beyond this
this uh consciousness just pure timeless
consciousness there's the
the literal infinity itself
so uh definitely i i loved how he
also expanded on that i recommend also
checking out if you haven't already
the infinity series that is free on his
channel
yep
likewise with bentino being a profound
influence and also that coming in
with many of these intuitive
realizations and
when we tap into rupert spyra a bit or
bentino
or a little bit of ramana maharshi
nasargata maharaj
muji etc
we pick up
something unique like with ramana
maharshi i picked up
sahaja samadhi and so
it's very it's like the tantric path or
the middle path or the middle way
or the goldilocks zone it's when you
take sahaja
your sudden enlightenments when you take
that and you
do the met you take that and you weave
it into
your daily activities integrated
integrated
exactly yep exactly and so
i take these beautiful bits from
all these different it's just so
incredible it's such a
that's one of the most important things
in my opinion to do
which is to create a
a lattice work or conceptual framework
or a world view that is very
perennial so i pull a lot from
exactly yes so so perennial means it's
found across the planet
so meaning across the planet the
different mystic traditions
across the planet point to the same one
end and so when you pull a little bit
from like sufi metaphysics
and then you pull a little bit from dao
to ching pull a little bit from zokchen
from theravada buddhism
from the old and new testament
from all these different sources what
happens is
you gain this incredible lattice work
that makes you like makes you like a
ninja
wow it's very indeed indeed it is very
cool to be able to read
from someone from an enlightened
enlightened being that
you never heard about but you see what
he is typing
and like for the normal person it would
be what the hell is he talking about
and you have never read these words but
you know exactly what they mean this
timeless wisdom
has this
passing along
and to be on the receiving side
of it after
dozens and dozens of
visits to these concepts
seeking for me it was five
years
and
five years of of
knowing what you are seeking exactly
like god realization i'm seeking this
or like seeking just happiness and you
did not know exactly
what it is the latter
i see so in that in that sense then
it would probably be like four four
years for me i guess but
it was actually recognized as god
realization
exactly like a year ago or so
or a year and a half ago probably
yeah and for me it's probably been
like six weeks
[Music]
because i would go to tatwa masi
you are that i am that we are that
and i would see that a couple dozen
times over the last let's say a couple
of years and especially like
this last summer i'd be looking at that
and i'd be like we are
it we are it we are it
yeah and like it would be so
fun to in a sense
recognize myself
today the way i see myself
six months ago is that
the way that i was getting it
was not from god realization but from
oneness in a sense it wasn't from
non-duality it was from
oneness these are very interestingly
intricate unp you we have to unpack the
words for it to make sense
but it's something like
oneness can mean
in a very physicalism
way oneness
that there you go that's probably the
easiest way to put it
if you think about oneness from a
physicalism way
that's probably where i was
six months ago or so i understood the
significance of consciousness and
significance of spirituality
and these types of things but i didn't
understand
that it really originates like the
awareness itself or even beyond
i mean like i would um say that
the oneness that most people are
relating to
is like the sense of connectedness the
sense of unity with all
human beings or with all beings in the
planet itself
but they don't actually go the step
beyond that which is
the realization of awareness which is
where where all of this dream appears
from
and and beyond that
so perfect and that's why i really like
the
the words physicalism oneness
yeah that's probably one of the best
ways to put it
and so in a sense we we revisit these
concepts so we were talking about this
lattice work and all of this timeless
wisdom coming down
through the upanishads or the doubted
qing
or the old and new testament or the sufi
metaphysics or the
end agents of theravada buddhism
zenzokshen whatever
it's coming from all of these different
mystic traditions
as different faces
different paths to the same one end it's
like they're different flavors
of ice cream but they're all ice cream
and you i would look at this
12 months ago i'd look at it six months
ago i'd look at it
even you know two three months ago two
months ago i'd be looking at it
but i didn't have that last
breakthrough satori until about six
weeks ago
where even the
physicalism itself became
more and more illusory in the
prioritization
of awareness and slash consciousness
as god as the god of realization and
that being
shared among all
8 billion units in this creation design
and then then all of the other creation
designs happening
and then in the last whatever two or
four weeks
is when the further is like
well what's the last thorn well the last
thorn
is awareness itself and that's why
you said that what is the ineffable
that's where
awareness originates from yeah
so you know this is so so fresh and so
new you know to to me and it's really
cool
i love the fact that you're here so
young is so important it's really
important for us to
to galvanize the resources to help
you sustain yourself
and grow and prosper and
in a sense you're very much like our
younger brother
and that it's really important for us to
help and also in many ways the older
brother
as you also share wisdoms that really
resonate
with us and teach us as well and so this
is
really sacred and
beautiful and
yeah i adore the the tennis is what we
call it
we call it tennis this is tennis it's
like the
yeah we're just hitting hitting the the
ball back
the same player one exactly
it's the same one in two different units
that are dreamed hitting the ball back
and forth talking about itself yeah
yeah it's hilarious it's so funny
and so i'm glad that we got to also
physicalism oneness because i hadn't had
a descriptor for it before but that's
that's really the descriptive for it and
the leap
it's a very intuitive leap that has to
happen to the eternity
of awareness as the prior as the prior
and that's a that's a difficult leap for
people to make
until you give them the analogies the
dream analogy is a good one
that's probably maybe a good place to go
um
and that's also probably another good
thing to mention to you is that
although you are very
much in the abidance of the awareness
itself
for you to also
continue to look up
are you familiar with words like maya
and leela in sanskrit um
familiar yes but i don't really use them
like for me
maya would be just the the play the
dream itself whatever appears
on the most superficial level yeah yeah
yep and then leela is the divine play
it's very pretty much synonymous yeah
very similar yeah very similar yeah
exactly
um except you know lila is more like the
divine play the game
that the one is playing and then
the mine is when you are trapped in
delusion my is the intoxication
exactly yeah yeah yep
so precisely and so basically what i was
getting at is that as you build it's
still important
for you to build out this sort of
lattice work
because being 20 and being where you're
at right now is amazing and fantastic
yet the more that you pick up
these sort of profound truths aphorisms
across the different timeless mystic
traditions
and and put those up in your lattice the
more and more
it will not only become natural for
you in abiding but also for your ability
to help people in your private
one-on-ones
more efficiently holding by itself in
the dream there's a natural attraction
to
exploring all kinds of different
past paths and
like um pretty much what you are
describing
like even even now even though
theoretically i could just
leave all videos alone i still
every time a rupert spyra or shunya
murti
or or muji or eckhart tolle poster video
that i watch it just naturally not not
not even for any purpose it's just
so natural it's just unfolding it's so
natural just unfolding exactly that's
good that you're you are doing that's
great
great probably a good place to go
next is the dream the dream analogy
because as above so below
as we go and for
a third of our lives go and sleep and
then for
a good portion of that we simulate out a
dream
and immerse ourselves into it in the
first person
observer perspective
as we do that there's no
separation between the observer and its
environment
you can't have a dream simulated dream
without an observer
so this as as that's below
so as above would be god's dream
the ones dreams these creation designs
as
dreams and we are that and we
are the immersed first person
agent and so
how do you like the dream analogy how do
you tell the dream analogy
it's very very useful and i always
use it use the dream analogy in the way
that
basically the same way that you go to
sleep
apparently and you have a dream
right you have a dream and you dream a
dream body a dream
universe and you are not the dream body
you are not the dream universe it's
obvious to you that you are not the
dream body not the dream universe
it's just appearing temporarily but you
are not that you are the consciousness
that is aware of it
so the same way right now this is the
exact
same dream that you are not the stream
body you are not
any of this universe you are that which
is dreaming it you are the
the consciousness modulating itself in
the present moment to appear as the
the universe as the body but you are not
um like literally
any of the dream the dream and the body
and the universe
comes and goes but the consciousness
itself is what you are
so that is um how how i
how i use it
i also want to share that
the more you are
the ego is dissolving you are much more
lucid
in the normal dreams also like well not
in the waking state
dream in the dream dream
in the dream you also
have much more lucid experiences you
actually wake up to the fact that
this is a dream literally inside the
dream not even with any practice you are
i
i am not practicing to be lucid in my
dreams but it's happening by itself i
start
flying consciously literally consciously
moving around the dream
watching the the the scenery watching
the trees
looking at at objects in the dream and
seeing how
they are similar to the waking state
dream and it's
absolutely profound very very beautiful
i've never had the experience where
in my dream i become
lucid so in my simulated dream at night
laying in the bed
so in this stream i go to bed and dream
where i become lucid
and then i choose to go to bed
in that dream and then make another
dream
no that did not happen to me i just want
it just came up
while you were saying that though and
that would be insane
[Music]
uh
a dream inside a dream
oh my gosh the simplicity of this
is right under our noses
it's closer to us than the images on the
screen that's so funny
yeah the way you describe it is great
do you feel like the reason why you have
oh wait let me pull up your quote first
your other dream quote
is uh if you know what you are
the dreamer of dreams then you
are not able to suffer
yes
a good one expand a bit for us
so the dreamer of the dream refers to
the consciousness that is modulating
itself to appear
as a dream so when you
know that this is a dream just like if
you put a vr set
okay you get into a game where there are
people shooting you
you will not be afraid you will not
suffer the fact that people are shooting
you
it will be just okay it's a play it's
not real
right so when you realize this is also a
dream
whatever appears is not real it's a vr
set that you are
seeing basically it's a dream then you
are just not able to suffer you are not
identified
with whatever appears so the same way
just like it's basically god realization
if you know you are the dreamer of the
dream
so of course with god realization you
are not able to suffer
exactly i'm glad you took us into the
vr territory as well because
you would never be playing a video game
and the character
yeah suffers in some way
and to mistaken that for
an actual experience of suffering
yeah it's like even if you put a vr set
you play an
a a super scary game like you have
jump scares and stuff okay even if you
are there
you will not be suffering you will not
be like that
oh oh okay it's just a game it's just
yes yes yeah i'm glad you took us into
that vr territory it's probably a good
time then to also ask you if you
because you played a lot of games
growing up i played
so many games growing up
i played a lot of sega genesis i played
a lot of playstation 1 and playstation 2
playstation 3 xbox
played a lot of xbox 360 played a lot of
pc games like warcraft and age of
empires and stuff like that so starcraft
so
what games did you play and then i'll
ask you the follow-up question after
that
i played a lot of where i
um games like um stickman i guess
stuff like that internet yeah yeah
many games on the internet because
they're so
old at this point yep late maple story
counter strike combat arms
um call of duty stalker
game and
league of legends
rf online terra
that's pretty much uh what i remember
right now maybe if you continue
expanding yes
yes yeah when we play call of duty
and we begin the battlefield battlefield
you know when we begin the the game of
call of duty or battlefield when the
characters spawn
in team deathmatch we don't say that
they're birthed
and when they die we don't say that they
die
just playing a game it would it would be
very much
actually um um
similar to how this apparent reality
works when this body mind dies
you just spawn in like another body mind
spawns
in its place so like if you go
to sleep and you have a dream and you
get run over
by a truck did you die no you did not
die there's just another dream
that replaced the other dream so
what you are can never die when this
body mind dies in the apparent waking
state
there's just another dream there's there
might be another body mind or
might be some kind of formless dream
maybe you don't even have a body mind
you just are some in some kind of other
dimension in which you don't need a body
mind
stuff like that anything literally
anything yeah
exactly even outside of this
the restrictions of this specific
creation design itself
where we go outside of the the
two eyes and four limbs and the
the carbon-based dna encoded vehicle and
we go to some formless
being that you pop into that
expression of and
it's really well
explained as a hit back i like that one
a lot
that was good and so is the
in the dream when you die you get run
over by a truck you move on to the next
stream
and in the game when you there's no
birth and death of the characters
and yeah and that's
that's why i believe rupert spyro talks
a lot about the whirlpool the whirlpool
analogy is a pretty good one in the
field
the field of
whatever we want to say the formless the
field of the formless
of awareness
we can say that the whirlpool of this
unit
[Music]
for personally like i don't really use
the wherepool analogy it's not very
too too clear for me so like i don't use
that
it's too clear or it's not clear enough
very clear for me
in the ocean right in the ocean yes
there's a little whirlpools
yes and the whirlpool ends and the next
whirlpool begins
something like that i see yeah
i see stuff it's very simple actually
yeah yeah i know i know yeah yeah
yeah this is another good part about the
tennis
getting cl close to that enough it
clarifies a lot i learn a lot
we help one another a lot yeah
so all right so the follow-up question
to the video games
is do you feel like
what we're building right now with
artificial general intelligence and
indistinguishable virtual realities
and neuralink and bio and neuro
technology all this type of stuff
it's sin it's being synthesized into
what's called like the metaverse
basically have you seen ready player one
the movie
no i recommend watching it the idea is
that in a couple of decades those
technologies will become so good
that we'll immerse ourselves into these
infinite
designer realities and that we will go
and
play in them for you know 80 years or
something
and that's what's up online if you if
you watch the anime
what's which what's which anime sword
art online
oh sword art online interesting
so they have a vr set and they put it
and they have a little
world a creation design in which you are
inside of it and it's basically a dream
within
a dream within a dream
wow cool
yeah i'm looking at it right now
interesting so
near future and play through various
virtual reality mmorpg worlds
yeah well that's what this is
do you feel do you think that's what
this is this is pretty much it
this is really apparent waking state is
like gta 5 with
upgraded graphics it's literally look
well not gta 5 just gta i guess
it's literally just an open world game
it's literally what god is playing right
now yeah
interesting so it's like the
it's almost like yeah waking state is
gta and then it's like
god is like the decentralized
kind of like playing the controller
yeah yeah yeah
beautiful and i'm gonna check out
sword art online it kind of reminds me a
bit of
did you ever see the midnight gospel
duncan trussell's show
he he kind of also enters into all of
these different
virtual worlds but that's um this is
pretty cool
um i'm happy that you pointed me to this
very interesting i i definitely have
heard incredible things about
uh anime and i haven't dived in in too
much
fun yeah and
yeah the signal finding the signal is
always the thing so
you i feel like this is probably a good
signal
over instead of the noise you know what
i mean signal instead of noise
what do you mean exactly you know like
when if you go on like
like television and you click through
channels it
is basically a bunch of polarization
propaganda and people trying to sell you
[ __ ] that you don't need and all this
type of garbage
versus if you like go and like buy the
doubted shing or something
okay but anime i would not uh say it
it's like the
chain but well well sword art online is
probably
at least it can probably help you and
make you like
uh bring up some creative ideas yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah i
know i know
i know um cool cool
yeah because it's important to point
people towards like what are like the
best
signal in anime and would you say that
sword art online is some of the best
signal
i would not say that i just mentioned it
because
you're saying about vr and what like
what is some of the best
signal in anime that you found
i really i really cannot say
i don't think any of them really touch
like
anything super profound but if your eyes
are profound if you are god realized
then you will see profanity
okay cool yeah look at you and yes
yeah i told you before we started the
show that i feel like it will be a good
idea to potentially see as we sort of
get into some of the financial
stabilization growth on
on your end if we can potentially
explore
maybe even having
your unit in los angeles and potentially
producing together the animated series
that we've both been
totally cool yeah it's great
chimps is awesome but it was even cooler
when
before i even mentioned it to you you
told me that
you also had the vision for it
it could be amazing it looks good it
does because
it's fun it's light it's just animation
and at the same time it's it will it
will actually make you
like holy [ __ ] this is this this
relates to the actual reality you can
actually
become god realized or become pulled
or thirsty for it through the animation
so it's totally amazing and it can be
like
um it just just if we if we go into it
it can just expand in amazing wonderful
ways
yeah chimps making people thirsty for
god realization
yeah and that's just the the first
sentence
yeah yeah exactly so
so you do feel like what we're building
right now
with the metaverse technologies like
here with the
going through various mmorpgs you feel
like this is that
and this is what exactly that
in the next couple of decades we will
have built out the
technology that enables that online
yeah yeah to go in yeah pretty much
pretty much it definitely is possible
there is no doubt too hard
in in my perception yep and i and i feel
like that's what the godhead
is and then it goes into the tail
again and then it goes to the godhead
and then there's the tail again
not the same reality we're not going to
come back to this one we've already
explored this one or experienced it
but there's going to be many there's an
infinite well that's what infinity is
you can
you can never finish infinity
yes
it already probably already went through
infinite cycles we are probably
experiencing
this dream very specific very
unique dream for the infinite time
already because well it's infinity
even if there are infinite amount of
dreams it they all it already went
through the infinite infinite amount of
times
i like in the the map analogy is a
really good one
because the map is in video games
it's bounded
what is the map analogy it's bounded the
map
in the corner of the screen in the game
like right here
it's it's a bounded map okay
but infinity is unbounded
there's no bounds and so you can never
finish exploring basically
exploring there's there's no end to lila
the divine play there's no end
to the divine play
and when i got that
ah that's just that's it that's what
happened
but at the same time that's why we
continue doing this
that's what sahaja samadhi or the middle
path or middle way
is is is when there's the weaving of the
realizations into the daily activities
because there's also the lazy fish
as fred davis talked about on the show
because you're the fish in the ocean
you are the ocean but you can think
about like your fishing ocean there's
like
lazy fish that happens
and it's kind of funny because yeah
sometimes people can
get really
will you expand on this yeah it's kind
of like
[Music]
people can become very
[ __ ] off in a cave
and people can also become
trapped in maya and that's what the
middle way is
you don't get trapped in the worldly
sensory pleasures
and you don't get trapped in the cave
i don't think if you are god realized
and you go to a cave you are really
trapped it's it's literally god's will
in that case
and it's also god's will in the case of
maya it's also god's will yeah there you
go
exactly and the in the middle way is to
god realize and to weave into the tank
the tantric path the social fabric yeah
it's all yeah so that's why when you
look out and you see people that are
chasing lamborghinis and
houses and yachts and private jets
you know just today i was just seeing
again another one of these like
become a millionaire in one year and i'm
like
my goodness it's just
yeah so that's god's will that's it as
well
so yep because the parable of the
prodigal son happens where somebody goes
and they're like
that's what i want that's what will make
me happy one million
externally seeking and then they hit a
breaking point and then they turn
inwards to consciousness or awareness
yeah
so cool and then maybe another
good topic is that
what have you what have you
found so far about
this if you have found anything you and
i just talked about a little bit
ago which is that
is the reason why you and i
have so many of the same
teachers is the reason that
they are the ones that are playing the
best tennis closest to the ineffable
and that's why we're gravitated towards
them
i would say they are just very simple
very clear very direct
that is why we are gravitated towards
that beautiful we don't want to waste
any time we just want the god
realization and beyond we don't
want to just basically
waste time on
like other stuff
because i definitely have no interest in
that that's why even eckhart tolle i'm
not really
watching him as much anymore because he
more relates to the
very unconscious people yeah and them at
that stage
about muji and rupert spyra and
sunya murti
in a higher level we can say of course
there's no doubt that eckhart tolle is
uh
extremely uh god realized but yeah
yeah that's that's a great way to put it
is to
speaking to those that are most
intoxicated by maya
whereas maybe shunya morty and rupert
spyra
muji are more for
those that are already in the
the physicalism oneness let's say
something like that yeah they're on the
final stages of
of actually realizing basically exactly
of course not all of them because you
see many people on muji
that they're not even serious about it
they're not they're not really
going to god realize anytime soon
probably
that but it happens
like you i remember one time there was
this one person who says i really want
it i really want it but he was not
willing to actually see
and abide and but even though he was
asking questions and asking questions if
i was muji i would just
okay listen you are not going to get it
right now
sit down maybe some other time it will
work because that
it was clearly a scene that there's no
way this guy is going to
actually because we are at the last
stage okay listen
there's an awareness that is ever
present isn't it so and he's just saying
no no but i don't know so you're not
serious there's no way
so i would just tell him sit down let
someone else speak that actually can get
it but
at the same time he was they were
talking and they were talking
and another person stood up and said
while you were talking to him i got it i
got it you cannot see
it it's it's what's seeing
[Music]
i love it i love it it is what is seeing
yeah yeah i love it i love it that's
what
saint francis bassisi said
that you are seeking what is seeing
yeah yeah you are looking for what
is looking exactly yep
yep amen and
yeah i like our little breakdown it's uh
it's it's a good way to view it is
sort of the different levels those that
are most trapped in ego might
gravitate more towards an eckhart tolle
and those that are a little bit more in
like the trans-personal states or the
oneness states
they might uh gravitate more towards
morty or
rupert spyra muji et cetera stuff like
that that's cool
a similar one to eckhart tolle would
probably be idea chanti as well
ashanti is another good one for yeah
interesting
interesting
do you have other ones that come to mind
that you think fill
the level of either like the eckharts or
the ruperts
stuff like that and into those
categories
the well echo like eckhart would be
i would say gangaji doesn't really um
um point to the absolute today infinity
it would probably be also for the people
still
um very much identified to
at least open up at least a bit it's not
even saying
like awareness right um so i would
probably put gangaji in that category
although she probably has books also up
in in a higher level
all of them probably have uh books on
all levels
right um similar to
eckhart tolle would actually be osha too
but at the same time interesting
also at the same time he he's gotten
higher levels yeah
yeah yeah um
[Music]
ramana maharishi of course uh very high
would you put ramana in
closer to like rupert's or closer to
like bentino's
oh bentino is very high of course very
direct
ramana would be a very very very simple
very direct also i would put it like
rupert spire basically yeah i think so
too yeah
if you have any more names and i can
like probably
miss our gothic does probably up also
the same as
rupert's fire basically and muji
very very similar to how mooji is
um agreed yeah articulating
like it's not you who is suffering it's
the person you think you are that's
super clear yeah yeah
so what about
do you know of other people that are
closer to the level of even
pulling the last thorn like bentino says
around awareness
and then recognizing that as the
absolute do you know others that are
in the beginning that would be that
would be muji
muji okay
um
bentino of course
they're probably the the like they're
they're the ones coming up right now i'm
not sure
of anyone else
like i don't remember anyone else have
you studied the neo advaita teachers
oh like newman i was actually watching
yeah
he's considered new advice right yeah
and he learned from tony parsons
yeah so i was actually watching it
yesterday
and when they say this is it
they refer to consciousness basically
but they don't say consciousness they
say this
well this is consciousness well in in
how
we are referring to consciousness so
yeah like what they're saying is
basically there is no me
the me is illusory illusory which is the
personal identity
so i completely agree with that but if
you take it out of context it can be
very stupid very silly that's that's why
bentino talked about it like it's
unstable like neo
advaita is unstable in a certain sense
because it's it's trying to get people
direct to
in a sense the absolute rather than
taking the first step to the
awareness and then the second it was
taking you to the absolute though
it's actually taking you to the
awareness
because when you say this is it how much
how much jim newman and tony parsons and
fred davis how much
of the neo advice have you watched
actually i watched only like
one video of jim newman okay okay yeah
so
i'll i'll break it down a little bit
more for you um
the
the the way that it's generally
portrayed is something along the lines
of
this is a dream this is an illusion
there is nobody here there is nobody
here doing
anything and that's very much like the
absolute
there's no one here doing anything
and
they definitely
how i would interpret there's no one
here doing anything
it means there's no personal identity
doing anything
in that case it's just the awareness
level it's not sure
sure i think they're declining even the
awareness
that's what i'm trying to say but um
from what i perceive
that's just not how i'm seeing it okay
yeah maybe
maybe after taking statements then i can
also see
yeah yeah how actually it is referring
only to the me to the personal identity
it's not saying anything about
consciousness if someone asked
is there consciousness no there's only
this they would say
but that's just because consciousness is
a concept and you think you know
consciousness but actually actual
consciousness is beyond knowing
in a way beyond conceptual knowing which
is what they refer to
as unknowing and knowing is actually
just pure knowing
in how i would say stuff is
and then they would say that there's no
there's no knowing happening
there's no there's no conceptual
knowledge
not knowing happening and something like
there's no observer
right so there's no awareness there's no
consciousness there's nothing like that
never in the personal sense like
i'm observing as a personal identity i'm
observing
no but there isn't observe being an
observation so let's put let's put it
into three levels
there's the physicalism where it's the
contracted ego
and then the leap happens up to the
observer or god realization or witness
and stuff like that and then there's the
next leap up which is removing the thorn
of even the observer or the awareness
that then
brings you to the absolute though no
attributes
no agent stuff like that so
ineffable and so what i'm saying neo
advaita does
is they go directly from the physical
and then they say that
there's simply what's happening in this
appearance
just that and that's all there and then
that's what in a sense they're trying to
get people to leap
up to that recognition of just
simply the appearance this and
so what when rather than that one step
and that's why it
even sometimes looks like it's it's just
it's very unstable in many
ways but yeah this sort of idea of a
two-step
god realization and then removing even
that thorn
that's a much more uh stable
step but i i appreciate the hits back
and i
i would probably also need to um
figure out a little bit more with sort
of
the instability of the neo advaita
teaching in a sense it's like the
egoic consciousness gets to just say ah
it's all a dream
okay i will go back to thinking i'm a
separate entity
in a dream you know
so in my in my perception it appears
that actually this is it when they say
this is it it's just
pointing to god realization it's not
pointing to
okay yeah fair okay got it got it got it
okay so that's cool so then that would
be
potentially maybe like gintoni here
something like that
and then
yeah i love those three sort of tiers
that we talked about those are really
strong
it's a really good way to sort of
visualize it
it's kind of like mass media
spirituality
and then like those that are really
trying to god realize
and then those that are trying to
recognize that the absolute or ineffable
yeah yeah
yeah that's cool so probably the last
question is what has it been like now
with the one-on-one private sessions in
terms of
how are you you just fielding people
like via
the dmu um and they're like i would love
to sign up or they sign up on your
website and then
what what is the process a specific link
and you just order a session
in a specific hour very automatic
and i get an email and i just uh
we just have the session we probably
communicate in dms also
and then what is so walk us through what
what it looks like do they have to fill
out any information like for example for
me
the way that i handle the you know we
call this mirroring
right in the tennis is like
excuse me that the
in a sense the more purified the
god-realized mirror
is the more they can vortex up and help
the other mirror purify clean up and so
usually what i do when i undergo this
process is i
ask questions to understand
where they're at in god realization and
so
yeah how do you yeah walk us through
your process it would be
very spontaneous so i cannot really say
what exactly is my process
i come very unprepared i see what the
person has to say
and from there we go and realize god
together and there's no doubt that you
are able to
realize god like there's no there's
nothing blocking you and if you say
but something is blocking me but i tell
you okay what is aware of that because
the awareness is the awareness blocked
no it's not blood that's it that is god
realization
so i just gave you a spoiler
that's beautiful yeah there's nothing
blocking you
you know what is blocking you
there's no what is blocking the
awareness from being
it's already here it's already ever
present awareness is already aware
there's no there's no blockage that's
just a thought that you
believe but there's an awareness of it
that is the key the awareness is the key
not whatever you think is the key
yeah yeah what is blocking the awareness
from being
here there's nothing blocking the
awareness from being here
just recognize the diamond necklace
that's already around your neck
awareness is the key and yet it's so
hilarious
how it's actually the most
funny thing is how difficult it is to
recognize the
the diamond already around our neck it's
so difficult
that at first i thought okay this is so
simple
everybody get it everybody will get it
but at some point i realized this is not
working
this is not working as efficiently as i
thought i thought it would
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah it's
like you you
yeah go ahead god you you go that's when
i decided that
okay listen follow my patreon use these
anthogens
that they will force you to disable the
ego so you can recognize what is real
and from there it will be much smoother
it will be
um like something gets deleted
whenever you use psychedelics there's no
doubt
so as you repeatedly like the same like
as if as if you are abiding and do these
yoga meditations on rupert spires
um youtube channel you follow that and
it dissolves more and more and more
but at least get to the point where you
realize what the hell i'm talking about
very clearly from there you will you
yourself will have this
absolute um clarity and thirst
on what you are actually looking for and
from there it's much
easier to to just tell you listen
there's an awareness
oh okay there's an awareness okay that's
it
just don't identify with anything but
most people cannot even
like understand like that the the mind
is so virile for them
that they are just not able to
it's weird it is it's it's so
interesting that we're wrapping up
on this exact point that the
realization of the diamond necklace is
so
profound and it's so beautiful piercing
the bayless veil
and then it's like [ __ ] it's that
simple and then you go and you take the
gold over to other people
and you're you're like the diamond's
there like that's the gold the diamonds
right here it's right here
this is what it is and then you're
you're and then you
watch as like all these ranges of
responses
from like i'm trapped in physicalism i
don't know what you're talking about all
the way up to things like
like they'll like make jokes about it
but they won't get it
that's so weird when that like they'll
make
jokes they'll be like ha ha yeah yeah
all oneness yeah
haha yeah the consciousness is there
it'll be like it'll be like also like
[ __ ] lol but they don't get it
yeah and but there are those and it is
so
so auspicious when you actually point to
someone listen the
the the awareness is here isn't it so
who is struggling who is looking for
what and he says
no one he actually understands
he actually realizes at that in an
instant with no
back and forth nothing just realize that
awareness is ever present
and that's it you are the awareness now
and that's so profound that's so
beautiful
i mean and then they come and thank you
thank you you changed my life
you made me realize i have no problems i
don't exist
and that's and so so simply and like
some other people that just
just cannot get it but that is exactly
why
i have this guidance on the patreon that
allows you to no matter what kind of
delusion loop you are in you are able to
just disconnect from that completely
and realize what i'm speaking about
yeah yep
yeah i love that through every maya
delusion loop
that and that's ultimately
the nature of what this is is all these
different
maya delusion loops across all of these
creation designs
and then just that gps callback as
bentino says
of union yoga hypnosis mystic
where you god realized who is like
by the way oh yeah that's
yeah yeah another yeah yeah that's
another good one for the masses yeah
i agree yeah
yep that is another good one for the
masses yeah and
that it's as simple as the recognition
that
awareness is ever present and that
awareness is already here there's
nothing blocking that
and then the thing about that is to be
careful because
even when somebody breaks through and
gets it we're talking about this with
fred
is that people can break through and get
it
and then it's great but then the
if they don't in a sense undergo
a process of recognizing that the light
bulb
as adi shanti says you want to stay
on rather than just the flicker
it still requires you to not in a sense
go back out into maya
seeking the intoxicating
pleasures and so there's in a sense that
abiding is something that not everybody
recognizes right away and that they can
go
they can get a taste of it and then go
off for 10 years distracted and then
be like what the f like yeah type thing
i had this
moment with my mother actually i pointed
to her
uh to the awareness and we and she was
oh she she got it for a moment
she was like oh my god are you abiding
in this bliss all the time and i'm like
yeah that's that's like normal and and
she
just after like five seconds she starts
asking trivial
questions again like why are you doing
this
like and it it it's like it is nonsense
like exactly
here every day listen these things come
and go they don't matter
literally they don't matter just abide
as the awareness but no
it's just not working it's like they
they don't
realize how significant uh
this awareness is yeah
yeah and we got to be careful to not
make it a personality teaching is
another thing that
fred pointed out to us that i thought
like there's um there's some people that
talk about
how like some people will try to
put a descriptor onto the ineffable
and they'll say that oh the ineffable is
anarchic
or it's creative or it's a divine play
it's lila
and whatnot and we have to be careful
because any of those can become
personality teachings in the sense of
when we do things like saying like come
to my
1 000 retreat and i will tell you
ultimate truth
you know that type of thing so then
there's a
very there's a very delicate
sort of transmission that needs to
happen that is very strategic
and surgical and precise and that is
not in service to
maya but is rather in service to the
ultimate and also what you're saying is
not just make someone intellectually
understand what you're speaking about
and then they just
use the intellectual understanding and
they say as if they have actually
realized experientially what you're
speaking about
is that what you're referring to
so maybe maybe more so that two things
first of all
that we color the absolute in the sense
of like
we the absolute's ineffable and then we
color it
with these descriptors
but it's attributeless and yet we color
it so we
i just did not see anyone who actually
did that
okay okay fair yeah i've seen a decent
amount of in a sense people
that are coloring
the ultimate
and then charging lots of money for it
type thing
and so there's a
there's a balance the strike between
using money as a fuel
for sharing
as close as we can in as humble of a way
as we can
while and the sort of opposite side of
that is to sort of
charge ridiculous amounts of money and
also say that my truth is the one
truth and nobody else has it until they
get it the way that i have it
and so it's like that's also really
important to
sort of just recognize you you there's
no like
we take our our unit
is the diamond or the
jewel and the jeweler the diamond it
refracts
the source light in its own expression
and so when this unit's expression and
when your
unit's expression each one of everybody
listening's expression
tries to play tennis around the
ineffable
they're doing it with their own units
coloration
did that make sense like
i just again i i cannot really relate to
that too much because i don't see anyone
coloring the absolute
if anyone would color the god
realization
but the absolute like okay fair yeah
anybody even talking about the absolute
really
so yeah fair okay
cool yeah
yeah so spot on
there's nothing blocking the awareness
that is already here
alright always already ever present and
free
awareness
thanks for coming on the show sebastian
thank you thank you thank you
i love learning about your story so
profound
so crucial that you found nth agents to
help you break through
definitely that is why it is totally my
recommendation to utilize these things
because
i do see too many people who are
um just intellectually understanding
uh awareness basically but
it's like you you see them and they are
they're still
identified with the mind it's and they
they don't realize it
so that is why my pointing is my highest
pointing would be to follow
the the guidance on the patreon and
realize
experientially utilizing the
theogens because there is no doubt there
there is no intellect there there is no
way for an intellectual understanding
it just disables egoic mind and you are
able to actually understand and
and it gives you a huge powerful boost
of of of of source basically
and uh definitely it is uh absolutely
crucial even you can realize
god without anthogens but
i just cannot i cannot say i recommend
it literally
i just i just cannot yeah i've done
so many on the anthogenic buffet and
they've helped so much i like how you
say
they disable the ego that's why the
literature scientifically is clear about
the quieting of the default mode network
and the enabling of so many new novel
connections to happen in the connectome
of the neural wiring diagram inside of
the human brain and that's what enables
you to
recognize the trees being alive because
you've never recognized that before
because you've walked around with a
little tree icon in your head
and then when you undergo some antiogens
you recognize
holy [ __ ] look at the sunlight shining
through every single one of the leaves
and look at the pattern that it's making
on the ground and look at that chipmunk
that just ran through and the squirrel
and the birds and
look at the i was one
one time in switzerland i was just
sitting near the
huge huge lake uh kind of looked like an
ocean
and i was looking at the sky and it was
a clear day
there was the sun and and you just
see how this is literal
infinity literally you understand that
this is timeless and you just see how
i cannot describe what you are seeing
but
it's like you are just perceiving
everything in such a different
light that super profound just
just the perception itself is so
profound
and then you you remember how it looks
and you are able to connect to that
while sober too so the way you are
realizing
the profound truths on psychedelics on
the theogens
you are able to connect to that uh kind
of a vibration within yourself
and able to perceive and realize these
things on the
on the instant to instant you don't have
to
to only be tripping and then it it works
it you literally it it it burns itself
into the consciousness
and then we re-baseline to that when
we're sober
as our natural state bliss peace
infinity eternity
we see the divine everywhere everywhere
we look we see god's face
it's a sufi aphorism
yeah like in theogens would be like
rupert spyra has these yoga meditations
right
then theogens are just the same thing
but like
10 000 times more powerful well they
disabled that
echoic default mode network style yeah
because otherwise you can't
it's so much more difficult to disable
yeah
exactly spot on i'm i'm super agree that
that's a massive gateway
we have to be more serious on as a
planet about the gateway event theogens
yeah yeah beautiful i mean
yeah so many things that we kind of
crushed
in conversation there the eternal
fireworks as well
there are so many good things sebastian
thank you for coming on the show
we love you thank you we're so grateful
thank you
so cool so cool this relationship now
is here it's divine it's so divine
everything is divine a relationship with
anyone is divine but this is like
extremely divine so divine
it's indescribable yes it is i love that
the pathless path to god realization an
awesome episode of sebastian key
again you can find his links in the bio
below to his instagram go and give him a
follow he has great content there
also his website and his blog his blog
is great content go and check that out
you can book a one-on-one session with
him
as well over there and support him on
patreon remember our boy
is in the process of stabilizing his
own absolute and god realization and
therefore financially also
would love to be able to grow that and
prosper so
support him there as well and
thank you very much for tuning in
everyone we love you we're grateful
we'd love to hear you love you love you
love you yes yes we would love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below let
us know how you feel about the episode
and what we discussed
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe if you haven't
share it with other people that you feel
like would it would bring value to
and that is all
the pathless path to god realization we
all
in our own unique style recognize the
diamond necklace that's already around
our necks
thank you much love peace
wow beautiful
talking to myself in a dream
you